how do you see the artists regarded in
france vs the u.s. you know you talked
about there was that great time right
after high school around that time we're
making that decision do you think the
artist is embraced as much in the US as
it is in in france or even in europe i
would just make a note about that
because I think that filmmakers I mean
are not that's where artists I think I
mean I think that small of a craft
artist I would say that would be more
people painters and I mean sculptures
these kind of people I think that it we
don't have to lose the industry side and
the craft of it and it's true that in
France it's seen as enough as a very
artistically thing which is great
sometimes but in other times which can
be also cumbersome because you have this
like when you I mean when people tell
you okay you are an artist you have to
make an artistic a movie sometimes it
can make people overthink and overkill
movie and and that's why I love in the
u.s. these craft which you are sharing
with the DP with your ad with producers
and you are constructing a movie
together with your bare hands either way
as i was telling you and I love this
concrete physical way of building the
movie almost as the same physical form
that the viewers are going to feel it in
a very visceral way so you're a
craftsperson yeah exactly that's how I
would define myself and that I love this
term because you have a long tradition
of in the sort of man kind of people of
carpenters of people building cathedrals
I mean when we make a movie of course
it's not as building a cathedral but in
a way it's kind of a small Cathedral you
have to build so and you're affecting
people yeah like you said cuz there's
movies that stay with us for years that
have changed us exactly exactly I want
to fake ppl anything that
it's not only a trick because some
people I love for example the way a
crystal and describes movies is like is
a magician is like building things for
people and i love it i love this side
this craft tricking side where people
don't know how the movie was made which
is amazing and yeah for me it's all
about that and but not to trick people
it's to trick people to make to make
them feel something
you